Speaker 1: Let's continue. We are going
next to Kansas. Why don't we go to Toby
from Kansas. Toby, you're on the
air. What's on your mind today?
Hello, can you hear me? Yes, I can.
Speaker 3: Hi, David. OK, so I had two questions,
the first one being being is this is sort of
likely that the Republicans take back the House
in 2022. Yes. What are the chances, do you
think, that Joe Biden would actually get
impeached in the House?
Speaker 1: That is
I think it's I hate to say this, but
I think if Republicans take the House.
It's quite likely that articles of impeachment
are filed now, it'll go nowhere in the Senate,
but I think that Republicans are determined in
order to make Trump look less stupid for having
been twice impeached to just impeach Biden, even
if there is no reason to do it. So I do think
it is a greater than 50 percent shot that Biden
has articles of impeachment filed against him. If
Republicans take the House in November of 20 to.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I'm I'm afraid I agree with
you and then to round it off,
what is your go to coffee order
Speaker 1: to cappuccino small. And now
here's the thing. A lot of people will tell
you you have to order a small cappuccino.
Really should only be one size. It's a six
pounds drink. It's not a big drink. And so
for me, a big red rag, a big red flag at
coffee places is if I see small, medium and large
cappuccino, I'm concerned. I'm concerned. Toby,
that's that's a distressing sight to see.
Speaker 3: This is this is the truth. I work as a
barista, and something that is really concerning
is the amount of people that order a macchiato
don't actually understand what that is.
Speaker 1: You know, there's a there's a cafe
that I used to go to in Manhattan. Where would you
when you would go in and order a macchiato, they
would say, you know, that's small, right? It's not
like the Starbucks thing. And I would, of course,
laugh and say, yeah, I know. But there's lots
of people that go in. They think a macchiato is
basically an eight ounce ice cream. You know,
Speaker 3: it is it is a shame.
Have I have a wonderful day.
Speaker 1: Thank you. Oh, by the way,
just one question. From the standpoint of latte
versus cappuccino, can you really tell the
difference? Is it just a different amount of foam?
Speaker 3: Yeah, it's all to do with the volume
and the. Yeah. The amount of foam in the milk.
Speaker 1: Got it. Very good. All right. Well,
I appreciate the call, Toby. For sure. Have a nice
day. All right. Glad to have been able to clear up
some issues of paramount importance, quite frankly